JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
I'm Juliet Ehimuan-Chiazor.
And I feel very
honored and really
delighted to be moderating
this panel of these very
inspiring women.
I'm going to start by
introducing them very briefly.
You are very familiar
with who they are.
So I'll start to
my immediate left.
This is Ibukun Awosika.
She's the first female
Chairman, Board of Directors,
First Bank of Nigeria Limited.
She's also the founder and CEO.
[APPLAUSE]
We're very proud.
She's also the founder and
CEO of the Chair Centre Group.
She's a multiple-award-winning
entrepreneur,
and the first
Nigerian recipient of
the prestigious International
Women Entrepreneurial Challenge
Award.
She currently sits
on many boards
and is a co-founder
and past chairperson
of Women In Business Management
and Public Service, Wimbiz.
[APPLAUSE]
Ibukun, thank you so much
for joining us today.
It
IBUKUN AWOSIKA:
You're most welcome.
JULIET EHIMUAN CHIAZOR:
We really appreciate it.
And we have TY Bello.
She is a multifaceted
woman with a few labels--
singer, songwriter,
photographer,
and philanthropist.
[APPLAUSE]
Prior to pursuing
a solo career, she
was a member of the
defunct gospel band, Kush.
She's also a member of
the Nigerian photography
collective, Depth of Field, and
was the official photographer
of the former
President of Nigeria.
She's best known for her
award-winning singles,
"Greenland," "Ekundayo", "This
Man," "Freedom," "Funmise,"
and "The Morning Songbook."
She stages annual
photography exhibition
to raise funds for orphans
across the country.
She's also a director of Link
a Child, an NGO dedicated
to propagating information
on orphanages in Nigeria,
and soliciting sponsorship
on their behalf.
[APPLAUSE]
It's good to have you here, TY.
TY BELLO: Thank you.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: So
to start the conversation,
this will be in two parts.
We're kicking off
with this panel.
And we'll have a second session
after the break with Dr. Oby
Ezekwesili.
So to start off, I'm going to
ask a relatively broad question
for each member of the panel,
starting with Mrs. Awosika.
So when we think about where
we are in our society today,
we're talking about
smashing the glass ceiling.
Is there still a glass ceiling?
We have made some progress.
In you opinion, is there
still a glass ceiling?
And what has been
your experience
around taking decisions to
help you smash or overcome
the glass ceiling?
IBUKUN AWOSIKA: OK, this glass
ceiling that won't go away.
I actually think that the
issue of the glass ceiling
is different for every
woman, and is also different
depending on where you are in
your career or your business
life.
It's different in
Nigeria, putting it
in context is
different depending
on what part of the country
you come from as well.
Because there are
different levels
that women are at, in terms
of having opportunities,
depending on what part of
the country you come from.
But I think that collectively,
when we look at it,
no matter what part of
the country you come from,
we have moved quite
a distance in terms
of the kind of opportunities
that women have.
But that's also a
function of social class.
Because that's another thing.
The average middle-class
to upper-class family
doesn't segregate between who
goes to school, whether it's
the male or the female child.
And the south, especially the
southwestern part of Nigeria,
would have every child from
middle class to upper class,
averagely have a
university education
and at least attempt to build
a career, one way or the other.
Now, there are other
factors that are then
beginning to come to play.
Because I think at
the starting point,
male and female start off
basically, equal footing.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Little things, [INAUDIBLE].
IBUKUN AWOSIKA: Yes.
But along the
path, other factors
that are not even as traditional
as we think begin to show up.
So now you've married a guy
who has his own insecurities.
And because of his
insecurities, he
would like a woman that he
can keep at home and control.
So that's not a societal factor.
That's an individual issue.
Or you've married a man who
just doesn't-- in his mind,
his mother was-- well,
is-- a housewife.
And he grew up with his
mother always been there.
And what he wants is a
wife who is a housewife.
I think the real issue is about
what the women want to do,
in terms of whatever kind
of ceiling is still there.
It's an individual
choice for every woman
to choose what life
you want to live.
And that comes into play.
We can play back
to our girl child,
and start to teach
the girls about having
the ability to make that
choice for themselves.
And that should
start from deciding
how far they want to go, by
having a sense of who they are.
And at a stage,
deciding who they
want to marry based on
who they want to be.
And choosing the spouse is a
key success factor in my books.
So if you have a
sense of who you
are, you have a sense of
how far you want to go,
when a nice-looking rich
and handsome guy who
wants a housewife comes
calling, you don't even listen.
Because he doesn't fit
where you want to go.
So it's not a matter of
that he wants to marry you.
It is a matter of do
you want to marry him?
Does he fit into the
life you want to live?
Does he fit into the future
you see for yourself?
Now, so as we take some
of the fundamental issues
and we move forward, we
then get into the workplace.
You get into the
workplace and then
you talk about does the woman
understand that she can't play
the feminine card anymore,
if she really wants
her respect in the workplace.
Does she know all that she's
got to earn a place by making
sure she's competent, she's
capable, she's equipped,
and she's ready to play.
Does she understand
she must have courage.
She must be focused.
She must able to
challenge status quo,
and fight for herself as well.
Does she know she
mustn't defer to the male
just because he's male.
As long as they're pairs, and
they have equal opportunity,
she should fight
for the position.
So there are many things
that come into play.
Because at the end
of the day, one thing
I can say in my
experience, is that when
you're good at what
you do, there's
a stage where you
can't be ignored,
whether you're male or female.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
That's true.
IBUKUN AWOSIKA: There
is a point where
the competition falls apart,
the gender card falls apart.
Because at the end
of the day, what
is the interest
of the shareholder
or the stakeholders?
They want to succeed at
whatever they want to do.
And when you're
facing the bare facts,
you're looking for the
best person for the job.
Now, there's all the issue
of OK, boys club, girls club.
OK, so?
Boys can network.
Girls can network too.
I actually think girls can
be more powerful networkers.
Why?
You can use the
network of your spouse.
And you can use
your own network.
And when you use
your network, you
use the network of your
friends and their spouses.
So you can play from both sides
even more than the guy can.
But your strongest weapon
is really about showing up.
Because the one thing nobody
can ignore is when you show up.
When you show up at your
table, and your capacity,
your capability,
your competence,
your ability is so open
for everybody to see.
You can't be ignored.
And that narrows the table.
And there's a point
where again, where I know
there's still a mindset issue
that we're dealing with.
But like I said, the
factors vary depending
on different circumstances.
But first, let's deal with us.
So I think when the girls
have said, OK, you know what?
We're ready to go
the [INAUDIBLE].
We're not making excuses,
saying oh, sorry.
I'm a girl.
OK, so I have children.
So I have a husband.
We work out how to
deal with those.
And I think a lot of girls
can deal with that now.
We find these solutions.
We're not simple women.
So we receive help.
We create help.
So that as a cook to cook,
what's my responsibility?
There must be food on
the table for my family.
Who cares who cooks the food?
As long as there's food there.
So my children must
be taken care of.
If I cannot afford to take 20
people to take care of them,
then I make it work.
Then somebody must
do my shopping.
You don't have to know.
I can call [INAUDIBLE],
and get everything
delivered into my kitchen.
There's a lot more ways
to get things done now.
So that the typical
traditional limitations
that women have can be removed.
And technology makes it easy.
Because then in the
middle of a meeting,
I can still check on my son
in university in England.
Just what's up?
Send him a message or response.
I'm going on.
I've checked in for the day.
And I'm still
sitting at a meeting.
So I think we can change.
We can definitely move forward.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: Great.
OBY EZEKWESILI : Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR: You're
raised some really important
points.
And I would like to
stay on those for a bit.
You talked about some factors.
For example, choice
of spouse, right?
And a lot of women actually do
value having a balanced home
and a peaceful home.
And that's very important.
And TY, very recently, you've
been very much in the press,
being instrumental
in transforming
the life of a bread
seller, to become a model.
TY BELLO: OK.
I'm glad we're talking
about this glass, the glass
ceiling and women making it
forward and pushing forward
in society.
My take on it is you
don't necessarily
have to be antagonistic
to break it.
It can be done with wisdom.
And it's all about maneuvering.
I would rather carry
a man along, than
drag him over kicking
and screaming, or going
at it alone.
I think psychologically,
it's better for most women
when they have the corporation
of whoever they're with.
Now, she said something
very important.
And that is a point
where most people are not
being mentored or taught enough,
is making that initial choice,
to find out who you should
be with in the first place.
For instance, I knew I
wanted to be an artist.
And I had an
ex-boyfriend who said,
I don't mind this
photography thing.
But I don't kind of see my
wife carrying cameras around.
And I took it seriously.
I did not think it was
just something on the side.
I wasn't going to marry him and
hope that he would support me
afterwards.
So I knew, for instance,
that for this lady,
the only way we could go far
was if we had cooperation.
Because you have to
realize that culture
is a very, very big part
of the whole scenario here.
And you can't do away with it.
You can't fight it, necessarily.
You can fight.
You can change, but with
wisdom, I think, yeah.
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
Great, thank you.
Ibukun, what's
your take on that?
IBUKUN AWOSIKA:
Well, to be honest,
I think half the battle
that women fight, here.
It's because we tend
to live out of context.
You know, we're
all well-educated
and quite exposed.
We've been everywhere.
And we've read [INAUDIBLE].
We've watched a lot of movies.
And a lot of girls
then get up and really
just want to declare
that kind of liberty
that they think a
Western woman has.
The reality is, it's
an approach that is
bound to fail from the onset.
I always talk about strategy.
There's no business
without a strategic plan.
And we're all comfortable
to have a strategic plan
for the next three years
of our business, five
years of our business.
Why don't we have a
strategic plan for our life?
That's affects where
we really want to go.
And when you're just got
a up a strategic plan
for your business, you
don't leave the context
of your environment out of it.
You take all the
factors around you
into consideration, in making
the decisions of how you walk
around it to achieve success.
That's really how we,
as an African woman,
and specifically as a
Nigerian, needs to look at it.
Reality is culture is on a
transformational journey.
TY BELLO: Yes, it is.
IBUKUN AWOSIKA: Society
doesn't change overnight.
And even if it
does, I don't know,
it would probably take a
million years for many things
in Nigeria to be totally done.
As you can see, our
parents go to school
abroad, get to
the highest level.
And just as they
retire, they decide
they want to go and
live in their village.
And you really can't
understand how.
The guy's left his village
since he was God knows what.
But it shows you that is quite
deep, this cultural thing.
Now, what that should say to us
as women is this is my context.
This is my environment.
There's certain values that are
important in my environment.
I want to play to win.
That's my goal.
How do I play to win
in my environment?
What does it cost me to
seek my husband's permission
for something I want to do?
Not because I don't
know what I want to do.
But is wisdom because I'd
rather run with his backing.
And if I fail, I
have someone who's
shoulder I can lean on, not
someone to say, I told you so.
You know?
I'll give you an example.
A young woman got transferred.
She works for a multinational.
And she always knew that she
will be up for her career
to go really far in
that multinational,
she'll be up for international
posting at any point in time.
Now, if I'm in that kind of
setting, and then you marry,
you're married.
And you can see the
opportunity come in.
And you'll be in
position for it.
First and foremost,
because I know
my job can have that context,
I will prepare my husband one
way or the other.
It will be a conversation that
we would have had that one.
Even if you're pretending
sometimes, like he,
you know they could just
transfer me to Mexico tomorrow.
How am I going to go to Mexico?
You, the children,
and all of that?
You're instigating
a conversation.
But you're preparing the ground.
So you would hear his opinion.
And listening to
him will help you
to know how to
formulate the strategy
to work the environment
of the home, in case
that situation arises.
So that his mind is
already conditioned.
And he may end up thinking
he is the one that's
convinced you to take the
posting because he thinks
he's good for the job.
But you already know you
want to go to Mexico.
So it's not how.
So I'm saying, he
gets the respect.
It gets the honor.
A man has a natural big ego.
What are you going
to do about that?
The bottom line is, how
do you manage his ego,
manage his respect,
and hist authority
as the head of
the house in a way
that you still
achieve your goal?
JULIET EHIMUAN-CHIAZOR:
So from the perspective
of entrepreneurship, you have
been quite the entrepreneur.
And I know you talk
about really focusing
on ethics and integrity, in
building the Chair Centre
Group.
And you had some
challenging situations,
which you were
able to turn around
for the good of the
business in the long run.
What advice do you have
for entrepreneurs going
through challenges, from the
perspective of navigating
through standing for
what you believe in,
holding your ground, and
actually being successful?
IBUKUN AWOSIKA: I think
the starting point
is that you have to have a
conversation with yourself,
at the very beginning,
and decide who you are
or who you want to be.
You must decide what your
value system will be.
You can never wait
to get to a crossroad
before you determine what
your value system is.
The reality is, if you
try to decide your value
system at a crossroad,
the pressure of the moment
will force you in a
different direction.
So what happened to me
was, as I was starting out
as a young girl in my
20s, I became a Christian.
Because I did start
off as a Muslim.
I was brought up
in a Muslim home.
I became a Christian.
And then I read this book.
It was written by some guy
about God owning his business.
And I found it very fascinating.
And I made a decision that I
wanted God to own my business.
And God can't own a business
where the value system
isn't based on the Bible.
So I built my own value
system on biblical principles.
And with that
conviction, I decided
some things I will not do.
The first, before I
became a Christian,
I started my business
for about a year.
But even at the beginning
of the business,
without the biblical principles.
Based on just my
upbringing, I decided
two things I will never do.
I was never going to sleep
with a man to get a job.
And I was never
going to pay a bribe.
Now, everybody assured me there
were a perfect formula to fail,
especially the bribe
in Nigerian context.
But you know, I think we
underestimate Nigerians.
That's the one thing
I can tell you.
Because if I built a business--
and this is our 28th year.
And I say that we've
lived by those principles,
then obviously there's
more than enough
room in this environment to
build the kind of business
that you want.
It's all about you.
And with those two
things said before me,
I started the journey.
Now, of course, there have
been many, many moments
where those values
have been challenged.
But I've been sometimes
really difficult and very
sad moments have
taken the decision
to stand by those
principles, paying
a high price, many instances.
But one thing I have
learned is this.
If you want to build
something to last,
you need to build
on the right values.
If you build on compromise,
the same compromises
will destroy you.
I mean, imagine a girl
who is willing to sleep
with men to get the contract.
You're only attractive
before you're conquered.
But reality is once
the man slept with you
once, your value is depreciated
by 100%, 80%, or 90%.
I mean, you can have
a repeat performance.
But he's overcome the challenge.
So there's no big deal.
So he doesn't have to give
you the big contract anymore.
he can give that to the next
new conquest that he wants.
And you can get the peanut.
If you pay a bribe,
yeah, there's
always somebody who is
willing to pay more than you.
And after a while,
it's a tough game.
I then decided
what I would rather
invest in is to invest time to
build service and build quality
product, and make my company
indispensable to any customer
that engages with us over time.
And yes, you might be slower
than your peers at this stage,
because there are some things
you're not willing to do.
But I've found in my
business that you're
far more sustainable over time.
And you know, at
crucial moments,
those principals were tested.
Because like in 2004,
when the government said,
OK ban on everything
related to furniture,
it was a function of OK,
a bill that was-- I'd
been in business
for 15 years then.
Was I now going to
become a smuggler?
I wasn't going to.
Because my principal
value system
I determined in advance was
not going to support that.
So the only option I had was
to do backward integration
and invest in
factories to support.
What we were doing
was producing.
We started local
production originally.
And then all the
factors in Nigeria
didn't allow us to fulfill
the dream I wanted.
So we started producing in OEM
factories around the world,
and bringing the
components back and adding
to create our own line.
So when the game changed,
all we did was OK, so what
are we allowed to bring in?
What are we not
allowed to bring in?
And we started working
back, and started having
JVs to produce in Nigeria.
Ultimately, staying
by our principals
encouraged us to build the
necessary factories here.
Now, I'll now tell
you the real offshoot.
When people talk about
oh, I sit on this board,
I sit on that board,
I do that now.
Frankly speaking,
the things that
actually made me
attractive to be invited
to sit on a number of boards
were those same things
that I went through
in those tough times.
It was the lessons I learned by
staying true to my principles.
It was the sacrifices I made.
Because I remember
when I was going
to join the board of Cadbury.
It was right after
Cadbury's crisis.
And I got a call the day
before from a friend of mine
that said, some people would
like to come and talk to you.
And I said, well, I'm
travelling tomorrow.
If they can see me tomorrow
morning, that will be fine.
And two British gentleman
came to my house.
We had conversation for 2 and
1/2 hours, and all of that.
Cadbury was basically trying
to set up a board of integrity.
And refusing to do
those things over time
was how I got on their list.
You never know who is watching.
You don't know who is watching.
Everybody is watching
what you're doing.
People might hail you, even when
you're doing the wrong thing.
You sound successful
and all of that.
But when the chips are
down, you know somebody
is going to say something.
Because somebody is watching.
And that's exactly
what happened.
They had a
[INAUDIBLE] list of 30
that was whittled down to 8,
that was whittled down to 6.
And then they ended
up with a list
of three-- myself, Atedo
Peterside, and [INAUDIBLE],
who joined the board.
And I've been on the board
of Cadbury since 2009.
The day I was invited to
have a chat with the group
chair of FBN Holding, he was
the Chair of the [INAUDIBLE]
Bank, PLC then.
It was simply for me to be
recruited to be Chairman
of the insurance company.
Because they were having
a startup company.
That is a joint venture with
Sanlam, of South Africa.
And they were
looking for someone
who had good experience
in driving a startup
with international partnership.
Now, it was the
challenge of 2004
that led me to a joint
venture partnership
with the largest French
manufacturer of [INAUDIBLE].
So I had that experience.
I had stock to my values
through the trial period.
And though every knowledge
I gained within that period
was what they needed for
what they wanted to do.
And that's how I was invited.
I actually had the conversation
about being the chair
of the insurance company.
But I didn't know that to even
be the chair of the insurance
company, I had to get on
the board of the bank.
So a month after, I just
got a message that said,
you've been appointed to
the board of First Bank.
I'm, like, board of First Bank?
How?
I was asked about joining
the insurance company.
So things you do for
the right reasons,
ultimately, people are watching.
Somebody will notice.
And it would create value.
So doing the right thing has
its own reward over time.
You might bear
pain for a season.
But there's a time when
everything comes together.
And I guess I turn down
more board invitations
than I accept.
So basically, there
is a high demand
right now for
people of integrity,
and women more than men.
And when the chips are
down, the whole world,
right now, is pushing
about getting more women
at the table.
Because there's a gender gap.
And once you don't have
women at the table,
you don't have a 360-degree
view of anything.
That's just the truth.
Because imagine me on
the board of Cadbury.
They're talking
about [INAUDIBLE].
When I listen to some of what
the men say, I just laugh.
Because I'm a mother.
Who buys stuff for the house?
It's the woman.
Who gets the children
to drink a beverage?
It is the woman that is
involved in that conversation.
If you take a
decision at a table
like, involving a
product like that,
you don't have the woman's
view, you will miss some points.
And that's the kind of thing
that happens in any boardroom
without women being in place.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: Great.
Thank you.
I think we're going to
have to take a break now.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very
much, Mrs. Awosika.
It's been great
having you with us.
We'll take a break and
then we'll carry on.
IBUKUN AWOSIKA:
Thank you very much.
JULIET EHUMIAN CHIAZOR:
IBUKUN AWOSIKA:
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
TY BELLO: Thank you.
IBUKUN AWOSIKA: I've got to run.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Welcome back, everyone.
I'm very delighted
that we now have
Doctor Oby Esekwesili with us.
[APPLAUSE]
OBY ESEKWESILI: Hi.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
So I'm just
going to start off going through
a few words from her profile.
And then we can get
into the conversation.
Once again, the theme
for this conversation
is smashing the glass ceiling.
And this is in honor of
International Women's Day.
So Dr. Oby Esekwesili is
a senior economic adviser
with Africa Economic Development
Policy Initiative, where
she advises reform-committed
African heads of states
on economic and policy issues.
She's co-founder of the
Bring Back Our Girls citizens
movement, advocating for the
safe rescue of the abducted 219
schoolgirls of Chibok
community in Borno State,
northern Nigeria.
From 2002 to 2007, Oby worked
for the federal government
of Nigeria, as Minister
of Education, Minister
of Solid Minerals.
She also serves on many boards,
locally and internationally,
and was named as one of
2015 Time Magazine's 100
most influential
people in the world.
I think that deserves
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
TY BELLO: Yes, yes.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: And
50 most powerful Africans,
by the "New Africa" magazine.
So once again, Oby, it's
so great to have you here.
Thank you for making it
all the way from Abuja.
OBY ESEKWESILI: I'm sweating.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
What can we get you?
OBY ESEKWESILI: That was meant
to make you feel a little bad--
[LAUGHTER]
--for making me make this trip.
It was tough.
It was a tough trip.
But I'm delighted
to be with you.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Yes, thank you.
OBY ESEKWESILI: I wish I could
have come earlier than exactly
when we scheduled.
But I couldn't
control the airways.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Well, thank you so much
for the commitment.
OBY ESEKWESILI: Yes.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
There's been
a lot of expectation and
excitement about you coming.
So it's great that you
were able to make it.
OBY ESEKWESILI: Thank you.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: So
to kick off the conversation,
so we're talking about smashing
the glass ceiling, right?
And I think it's
worth starting out
to just ask the question--
in your opinion,
is there still a glass ceiling?
We've come some way.
Maybe a long way, maybe
not enough progress.
But we've come some
way over the years.
Do you feel there's
still a glass ceiling?
And in your experience, what
have some examples of where
you had to take
specific decisions
to smash that glass ceiling?
OBY ESEKWESILI: Wow, that's,
like, many questions in one.
OK, so let me start
by saying what
a great honor it is for me to
be sitting with a wonderful-- I
think you set the
standard for what it means
to be a mentor now, isn't it?
To be able to discover talent
and to go all the way out
to offer opportunity?
[APPLAUSE]
People may have their
different angles on this.
But when I first saw
it, I tweeted at you.
And I said, this is a brilliant
thing that you've done.
So please, I join everybody in
applauding what you've done.
You've not done it for
just that young woman.
You've basically sent a
message to many young women
that opportunity just needs
some level of diligence.
Olajumoke was
diligently working hard.
She was not doing something
else when opportunity met her.
Thank you.
TY BELLO: Thank you.
OBY ESEKWESILI:
Thank you so much.
Glass ceiling is anything
that may not be-- well,
that's exact why it's glass.
Because sometimes you're
not supposed to see it.
But it's somewhat
there, standing
as an obstacle, as a
constraint to the progression
of a woman in the
place of career,
occupation, and profession.
And so with glass
ceiling, there was a time
in the history of the
world when it was perfectly
normal for women to
have no aspiration
toward any occupation,
career, or profession.
And so at that time,
when the awakening begun
to permeate through some set of
women, who dared to challenge
that idea, that all
the woman needed to do
was be a lovely
consort of a man,
and sit around with other
women, just fan themselves,
and have an afternoon tea.
You know?
When some women began
to challenge that,
they needed to be able to
carry many more voices along
with them.
And over time, that
conversation began
to happen, that what are
the barriers to this,
to women being able to
fulfill their talent?
And it went from just
that socialization,
you know, that
solution expectation,
that it was not necessary.
A man could do the work,
take care of everyone.
And so why are you
wasting your time,
trying to do what a man can do?
So you have that.
You also have
religious angles to it,
where some of the people
who didn't completely
read their Bible
well sort of thought
that when God created
Adam and Eve, he did
say, to Eve, take half
the brain of Adam.
There's nowhere in the scripture
that that's contained at all.
So clearly, God did not have
an intention for a woman to be,
in any way, less
than a human being.
As a matter of fact, I
normally say to people,
that in Genesis
1:26, he actually
expressly, in that
conversation, said,
male and female created
[INAUDIBLE] death.
And then it was after that,
in 28 of that same Genesis 1,
he then says, be fruitful.
JULIET EHUMIAN
CHIAZOR: Multiply.
OBY ESEKWESILI: Multiply.
Replenish the earth.
Dominate.
subdue.
Who was he speaking to?
He was speaking to
both males and females.
So if he had an intention
for any one of them
to be subordinated in terms
of their intellectual capacity
to be the best
that they could be,
he would expressly have said it.
Even though God does not speak
too often, when he speaks,
he is very composed in
trying to convey his message.
So religious is there,
for the human mind,
where they created a barrier.
And then there are certain
things that are geographical,
where in certain environments,
they just need topography
and the geography of
it means that there
is an obstacle to women
being able to respond
to some of the kind of context
within which they operate.
And of course, economic,
family issues, and all of that.
All these obstacles and
barriers act as glass ceiling.
But when you now take
it to the micro level,
a glass ceiling is whatever
exists in terms of the way
that human resources
is incentivized
within the workplace.
And if it is incentivized
in a particular way,
any part of it that hinders
the progress of women
is a glass ceiling.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: Yeah.
OBY ESEKWESILI: So if the
incentive in the workplace
does not make itself amenable--
JULIET EHUMIAN
CHIAZOR: Enabling.
OBY ESEKWESILI: And
enabling-- that's
the word-- enabling
of women, because
of some of the
variations in the pattern
and the lives of women that
could require the workplace
to adapt.
And with that adaptability, help
them to overcome those hidden
barriers.
Then you have a glass ceiling.
So I've taken it from the global
to the macro, and then to the--
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: Yes.
OBY ESEKWESILI: To the
femme level, isn't it?
JULIET EHUMIAN
CHIAZOR: Absolutely.
And to the personal level.
OBY ESEKWESILI: And
to the personal level.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: From
your own personal experience,
because you're
quite accomplished.
And one can say, you're a
great example of someone
who's been able to
break potentially
many ceilings along the way--
[APPLAUSE]
OBY ESEKWESILI: Ah,
that's [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Can you share an example
of a situation in your life
where you had to take decisions
consciously to help
you break through?
OBY ESEKWESILI: You see,
one of the things that I
loved about what
Ibukun was saying
is she used the word contextual.
I don't know in what
light she was saying it.
But I think I heard
that word, contextual.
Context is so important.
And in policy school, I was
taught that without context,
you run into trouble.
The reason I say this is
that there are some women,
obviously, who have somehow
managed to not see this glass,
even when it was--
[LAUGHTER]
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Right there.
OBY ESEKWESILI: I don't know
why some of you are laughing.
Just don't see the glass.
You just work through.
And before the glass knows,
you have walked through.
It's probably
shattered and broken.
But you just keep walking.
But it's not the same for
all of our experiences.
So my sense is where I have--
I'm trying so hard to say,
that this was the exact moment
that I felt like somebody tried
to stop me on my
part because I'm
a woman in my expression
of my calling,
in my expression of my talent.
And I'm running into a block.
And that's probably because
another important part
of the glass
ceiling conversation
is actually the glass ceiling
that the individual places
on themselves.
OK?
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: Yeah.
OBY ESEKWESILI: So if there
is a mental roadblock,
that's a glass ceiling.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: Yeah.
OBY ESEKWESILI: When
a woman sort of says
to herself, every time that
somebody does something to me,
it's because I'm a
woman, that's a crush.
And it's going to
always take you down.
There's nowhere else to go.
So just being able to
have a mindset shift
can be a very important, as
part of the way of shattering
the glass ceiling.
But where, I would say,
that I have come face
to face with this matter
of oh boy, you're a woman,
is actually not the
workplace experience.
It's the global
experience, where
culturally-- which is
part of the glass ceiling
that we see in the country
a lot-- people sort of
have make presumptions about
how power relationship ought
to look like.
If they've made
assumptions, and if they
have these presumptuous
attitude, then what
they're going to think it
is why should a woman appear
to be strong?
So you can have instances where
people say, you are so strong.
Oh!
I wonder who Oby
Esekwesili's husband is.
And I'm thinking
to myself, if only
I knew that I have
a husband who,
if he just gives me
one eye like this,
I would just find
in seat quietly.
Because, you know?
You know.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: Yeah.
OBY ESEKWESILI: So that's my
own experience of glass ceiling.
It's a macro, level 1.
It's not the level where, in
my profession, in my work,
anyone has said to
me, you're a woman.
So there are limitations
that we must place on you.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: Yeah.
I certainly do agree that
context varies from one person
to another, and actually
plays a key role
in looking at this holistically.
And the fact that the mental
block is a very big one
to break through.
And thinking about
that mental block,
sometimes that comes
from the cultural context
that we find ourselves in.
So my next question
would be to TY.
And thank you for staying on.
TY BELLO: Thank you.
OBY ESEKWESILI: You're welcome.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
From a cultural perspective,
what role do you see
our culture playing
around either creating limiting
or expansive opportunities
for women?
TY BELLO: Well, like she said,
I can only speak for myself
in certain instances.
Because I know, for
instance, I'm a photographer.
And I remember when I
started making images,
and my images started
getting noticed.
TY Bello was a man.
And wherever I showed
up, people were shocked.
And they're, like, oh,
is your guy on his way?
And I'm like, this is he.
You know?
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
She is he.
TY BELLO: She is he.
You know?
But I believe it's
not just culture.
I also think it's history.
How many women have done this?
And how many women
have done that?
So if no woman has
done this, so what
gives you the audacity
to think that you can?
I can give an example.
When I got the opportunity,
in the last administration,
to document the presidency on
a very, very intimate level,
and to go behind the scenes
and actually photograph what
happened, I realized that it
was important for history.
I don't know who Abacha was.
I don't know how he smiled.
I don't know who
got to document him.
Yes, we saw him behind
the dark sunglasses.
We saw him shake a few hands.
But we never saw any
vulnerable moment.
We never saw him in doubt.
And I felt like, OK, I need
to take on this job well.
And I know that I'm
surrounded by men.
surrounded by security,
that are going to try and
create boundaries for me,
to tell me how far I can
go based on how far people
in history have gone.
So for instance, when
people in government walk,
you don't move close
beyond a certain distance.
You don't move close
beyond a certain level.
And I'm like, no.
I want to get this shot.
I'm shooting wide angle.
I need to move closer.
So it was always a struggle.
But I do realize something--
that because I fought hard,
and because I constantly
broke barriers,
people who have come after me
have found it a little easier.
They haven't had to explain.
And they haven't
had to show work.
They haven't had to
stand for 72 hours
to let them know,
yes, I'm a woman.
But I am tough.
And I'm strong.
I will hold my
camera, two of them.
I'll hold my cameras in
my hand for 72 hours.
And I will not budge.
Because I'm serious
about what I'm doing.
So sometimes I think
it's working extra hard,
knowing that it's
not just about you
and your own
personal experience.
But realizing that every
time you push boundaries,
you're creating and
you're writing history.
You're telling a new story,
that somebody else can say, hey,
this is how it's done.
You create new.
This is how it's done.
You know?
[APPLAUSE]
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: Great.
And you've been quite
successful in transitioning
from a singer/songwriter
to a photographer.
TY BELLO: Oh, now I'm
trying to transition back
It's kind of tough now.
OBY ESEKWESILI: So I think
you've alluded to that.
But just in a bit more
detail, some of the things
that you did, or
your unique selling
point, around being able
to successfully make
that transition.
And actually, being
dominant in an industry that
is highly occupied by men.
TY BELLO: It's about
creating new definitions.
I remember when I told
my mom and her friends
that I wanted to be a
photographer in 1999, a very
close auntie, who
really cared about me,
was, like, [INAUDIBLE] why now?
Do you understand?
Because prior to
that, in her mind,
a photographer is someone who is
struggling and carries a camera
and is with bathroom sleepers.
You know?
They did not have a picture
of what I was aspiring to.
Unfortunately,
thank goodness, they
didn't know that I didn't
have a picture either.
It's just that I had a very
strong conviction that this
is something I'm meant to do.
I don't know why I'm
meant to do this.
But I know that I can do this.
But I also found out
that it's all the same.
It's about composition
and telling stories.
You write a song,
you tell a story.
You make an image,
What I do with my work is
to tell people stories.
Even when I take a
portrait of a woman,
I want her to see
herself differently.
Do you understand?
It's so extreme that sometimes
I would photograph someone.
And I would meet them
two years down the line,
I can't recognize them.
Because I have, in my
head, created this persona.
And that is all that I see.
I see every woman at her
highest and most beautiful,
and the strongest.
And I sell them that story.
And when they believe
the story, they
become that person
in front of my lens.
And it's is the same
thing with music.
So I find it very easy to go
back and forth between the two
mediums.
Because it's exactly
the same thing.
You're trying to inspire people.
You're trying to show them
this is really who you are.
Or even if I'm just
reiterating who I am,
you know, and becoming a
mirror for other people.
And so that's why it's so
easy to go between the two art
forms for me.
JULIET EHUMIAN
CHIAZOR: Fantastic.
TY BELLO: Thank you.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
That's great.
And I think that's
very powerful as well,
getting people to see the
grandest version of themselves,
and believing that, and
having that come through
in photography.
TY BELLO: Yeah.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Oby, you've
been very vocal about the Bring
Back Our Girls Campaign, which
is a very worthwhile cause.
And certainly, our
hearts and prayers
go to the girls
and their families.
Do you feel gender has
played a role at all?
Do you feel equally supported
by men in this campaign?
OBY ESEKWESILI: Oh, actually, a
lot of the people who came out
on the 13th of April, when we
had asked our citizens to come
out after many weeks of
social media advocacy,
and we went to do a physical
advocacy by turning up
at the unity fountain, a lot
of the people who came out
were men also.
But it was mostly
women that co-convened.
So we had [INAUDIBLE]
of a Laos man
who was really the
young woman that said,
social media is good.
But it looks like
these people are not.
So it's important that
you see that people
are on the straight,
really impress that.
JULIET EHUMIAN
CHIAZOR: Of course.
OBY EZEKWESILI: --in
the rescue of the girls.
And then Miriam
[INAUDIBLE], saw that
through [INAUDIBLE] and
I, and then [INAUDIBLE].
So we then began to convene
with people to come out
of that [INAUDIBLE].
And many men came out.
And for majority of the men that
have connected to the tragedy,
it's been because
they would always
say, I don't want to
imagine my daughter
in the hand of terrorists, or
in the hands of terrorists.
If we set the standard that it
is perfectly OK for the poorer
segment of our society to good
through tragedies of the kind
that the Chibok community
has gone through,
that the kind of the
parents of our Chibok girls
have gone through,
and we, the elite,
can find the moment to
sit down and discuss
whether it was-- should they
have done this or should they?
Oh, come on.
If children that
I give birth to,
or any of the other elite class
give birth to were abducted,
you think the government would
have kept quiet for as long
as it did?
It would never have happened.
It's simply that we are now
a society where we actually
are insulated and isolated
from the poorer segment.
So if it happens, it's one
of the things that happened.
We can comfortably just
walk on by, walk on by.
I command, for our Chibok
girls, on the basis
of my sense of outrage that
those girls were completely
being ignored by the
system that should
have responded to
the distress call
that they had been abducted.
The issue is where
are the Chibok girls?
Where are girls
who went to school?
If you asked me to explain
my personal connection
to their story, that's
easy and simple.
And I would do it.
Brono State was the key state
alongside [? Ubi, ?] that
when I was Minister
of Education, had
the worst poverty level in
education, girls and boys.
So for every four
young men in school,
only one girl in school.
And we needed to bridge
this disparity in education.
So Brono state was a
profile sate for us.
In fact, it was a major
state of intervention.
It was this lovely young
woman, Ayesha [INAUDIBLE]
was my task team person
for gender education,
you know, girl child
education reforms.
So for a new state,
it was major.
Now, when those girls were
abducted, I was angry.
Because I sort of
thought, so parents
who were convinced, in a
very difficult environment,
to send their doctors to school,
then we didn't safeguard them,
they are gone.
And they are with Boko Haram.
And all we're going
to do, as a society,
is say, another
one bites the dust.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Totally agree.
OBY EZEKWESILI: I
wasn't going to.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: Yes.
I think, definitely,
it goes without saying,
that fact that it is a
tragedy in our society,
to have that happen, because
you have been such a powerhouse,
standing firm for
what you believe in.
So it's really
speaking to people
who go through
situations where you're
trying to fight for a cause.
You're trying to take a stand,
either as a man or a woman.
But in this context, as a woman.
And then you're having a
lot of external challenges
and feedback, being able
to really stand firm
in that, inspiring
people in that situation.
OBY EZEKWESILI: No, I get
your point, which is basically
to say to people in
my response, you've
got to set your
eyes on the ball.
You know, the girls were more
important than anything anybody
was doing.
I mean, one of the
things that happened
in the course of
the advocacy, where
young men were sent to beat
us up, at the Unity Fountain.
And some of those
young men, they
would run all the way
to try to hit at me.
And something would say to
them, we can't hit this woman.
And they would run back.
They hit a couple of our people.
But they would come
all the way again.
And they would sort of,
like, wanting to push.
And something would
just hold them back.
And they would run back.
I saw that.
So whatever it is that
you can experience,
we experienced in this advocacy.
And for me, it was one
of the saddest things.
But what you've got
to say to yourself,
taking that inspirational
window on this,
is look-- what costs
can I possibly pay now,
that can come close
to what these girls?
I keep wondering, that 219 young
women interested in education.
Can you imagine,
with all that they've
been through, that we then find
these girls and rescue them?
These girls would be
the greatest symbol
for girl child--
AUDIENCE: Education.
OBY EZEKWESILI: You understand?
They will be the
greatest symbol.
JULIET EHUMIAN
CHIAZOR: Absolutely.
OBY EZEKWESILI: All
through the ages,
any other parent that would
say, my child would not
go to school.
These children would be like
a reflector saying to them,
are you really sure?
Just look at me.
I went through all of this.
I have now gone back and
completed my education.
See how I am.
Are you saying that like
daughter cannot be like me?
It would be you and I,
now needing to plead.
It would be those girls
making a clear statement.
And it would be legacy
for the people of Chibok.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Yeah, absolutely.
Especially as we talk about
education, education for women
at all levels, in the
rural areas and everywhere.
As a nation, we have a
responsibility to the girls.
And I think we are all united in
our intentions and our prayers,
that the girls do actually
come back home safely
to their families.
What's then, the biggest impact
or cost of speaking your mind?
Not necessarily about
this campaign in General
OBY EZEKWESILI: Yes.
And knock on my head, when
I was younger, you know?
[LAUGHTER]
You can relate, right?
They did it to you also.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: I
think we can all relate.
OBY EZEKWESILI: Yes!
[LAUGHTER]
But it was helpful
that I had parents
that encouraged a voice.
You know?
They encouraged voice.
They wanted us to take
ownership of our conviction.
So my dad always used the time,
courage of conviction a lot,
in raising us.
And so a lot of the
times when I think
of my opinion, my
view on an issue,
I am saying it an
expression of my values?
If it's an expression
of my values,
I'm not prepared to negotiate.
Because it's OK to
negotiate everything.
But my values?
No.
I wouldn't negotiate my values.
My voice on issues
are a reflection
of the values that
I hold strong,
and that I hold dear to.
Yeah.
TY BELLO: That's fantastic.
JULIET EHUMIAN
CHIAZOR: Fantastic.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
When we look
at the context in
the country today,
we've got a lot of challenges.
We have a devaluation
of the naira,
various corrupt practices, etc.
What advice do you have
for young people in Nigeria
today, in terms of how
they can apply themselves,
not giving up on any
dreams that they have,
you can still be the
best that you can be.
You can still come out of
all of this in triumph.
OBY EZEKWESILI: My
first thing would
be that the flip side of
every crisis situation
is an opportunity
waiting to be harnessed.
And so if there is anything
that a young person should
be thinking about
right now, that
would be what are the problems
that this particular moment
requires people to be solving?
What are the problems that
go with a time like this?
Because if I can
identify those problems,
and I can figure out the
solutions to those problems,
I actually stand a chance of
not just solving problems,
but having to a living.
So if it is basically about
people trying to figure out
what they can do
for a living, that
would be a good
way to think of it.
Because in crisis situation,
existing solutions
no longer work.
Right?
Because existing solutions were
OK for a different context.
You know?
So thinking of it that
way just sort of makes
you an entrepreneur.
And then the
entrepreneurial mindset
is the mindset of
the problem solver.
And so you've got to
think of it that way.
Because then it
unburdens you from saying
we're all in trouble.
You can distinguish yourself.
I can identify the various
problems or the different sets
of segments of society.
And this what I can solve--
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: And the
opportunities that it creates.
OBY EZEKWESILI: --and
these are the opportunities
that are created.
Then the second thing has to be
if I am in a changing context,
then I need to be thinking,
am I equipped for this change?
Am I equipped to handle it?
You know, because as
circumstances change,
the skills with which you're
going to have to deal with,
the changing context
would have to change also.
But if you still stuck
in person that you've
been, in the expectations
that you've had,
in the possibilities that you
can see, they you're stuck.
You know, it's a dangerous
place to be stuck,
just knowing what
you knew yesterday.
Yesterday is gone, people.
Today is new.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Needs new ideas.
OBY EZEKWESILI: And every
new day requires new skills--
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
New ideas.
OBY EZEKWESILI: New thoughts,
new ideas, new ways,
new partnerships, new
orientations, new attitudes.
And then a number three would
be to actually reach out.
Reach out.
It's a threat to be too
small in a world that
is more and more global.
OK?
So you must reach out.
I see some of the brilliance
of the generation,
your generation.
I see the brilliance.
But I also see a certain
amount of self adulation,
and a sense of
dysfunctional individualism.
So people just love
the idea that it's
I am the champion who is doing
this thing, all by myself.
No, today's world is a world
of collaborative partnerships.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: TY,
what's your take on that?
TY BELLO: I'd like
to add to that.
This is the age of social media.
And social media
means communication
and conversations.
And I find that
there is a deception
to think that it's
just a conversation,
and it's not real.
So we don't realize
that we are actually
part of the conversation,
and that we actually
make a difference.
I mean, it sounds very blase.
Like, you make a difference.
But it's not just speaking.
It's deciding what your
posture is concerning
the problem that exists.
And the fact that you
may not be able to prefer
a general solution
to everything.
But you have a
solution for something.
One of my biggest
mantras is do for one
what you would do for all.
And letting people realize that,
that solution that you have,
that can help your
neighbor, the fact
that you can share
generator with your neighbor
to help him save costs.
Do you not understand?
Just that little tiny
solution goes a long way
in you actually being
part of a conversation
than tweeting at other
people and criticizing them,
and telling them what
to do and how to do,
is within your own parameter,
within your own boundaries.
What changes can you make?
And then starting
with that, I think.
I think it's a small idea.
But I think it'll go very far.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Thank you so much.
OBY EZEKWESILI: But let
me have a final word
and say to the women that are
here, and that are listening,
the pressure on the
younger generation
of women professionals is much
more than we even coped with.
It's a world that is
much more fast paced.
And the kind of expectations
that are placed on you
are more varied.
As a woman, one
tool that I use is
what I call my five realities.
My five realities
are these-- number
one reality is my
reality as a human being.
It is in that reality,
as a human being,
that I have been given that
talent by the Almighty.
That talent is unique to me.
It's my authentic personality.
And it is the gift that
I have, that education
would have enhanced.
And so in that, my reality
as a unique individual,
I can be anything
that I choose to be.
I can be a photographer.
I can be a Google manager.
I can be a radio station owner.
I can be a lawyer.
I can be a doctor.
I can be a teacher.
I can be anything
that I choose to be.
And what I need is to find
what would enable maybe that.
And if there be any glass
ceiling standing between me
and what I can
be, I'm just going
to walk through that glass.
Your second reality,
my second reality,
my reality as the product of
two people, a mom and a dad,
they give me the
history that is mine.
There would not be me
if a certain Benjamin
and a certain Cecelia
did not come together.
If I neglect that, my
reality, I lose my history.
I lose everything
that is supposed
to enable me to understand
where I have come from.
So my reality as a
daughter is very important.
My reality as a daughter
is what enables me to not
repeat the mistakes
that my mother made,
or to repeat the mistakes
that my dad made.
Then my third reality is
my reality as a sibling.
Even if I didn't have
brothers and sisters,
I must have had cousins.
Because this is
Africa, after all.
So that reality enables
my socialization.
My reality as a sibling means
that I am a sister to a brother
or to a sister, or to cousins.
Now, what do they do for me?
They teach me how to lead.
Because in the early
days, of my growing
up as a sister to brothers
and to a sister, what happened
was that I needed to be
able to persuade them
that it was right for us
to do this or to do that.
If I didn't persuade
them, I didn't
get people who followed me
to do any particular thing.
I learned persuasion
by being a sister.
Learned leadership by being able
to convince them to follow me.
Then your fourth reality is
likely to be your reality
as a wife.
The companion of
this wonderful man
that you decided, of all men,
that you are going to marry.
I mean, that's some
incredible reality.
Its partnership.
Marriage teaches
you partnership.
It teaches you how to not live
for yourself alone, to learn
how to live for somebody
else, to sacrifice, to get
to the point of intimacy
that marriage is about.
Then your final possible
reality is the reality as a mom.
The reality as a mom is an
entirely different experience.
It's this experience
where you're preparing
the world for the future.
That future that you're
preparing the world for
is going to be defined by
what you deposit in the twins.
The world is waiting for the
twins on the business of what
you do with them today.
You're going to unleash either
great children of stature
on society, or they are
going to be terrorists.
Which one should you
unleash on the world?
It's a reality.
So being a mom, being able
to invest in the children,
so important.
Your reality.
Now, with all these
five realities,
how do I manage to
cope as a woman?
Is your question
to yourself, right?
You're going to say, ah, there's
not a single of my reality
that should be traded
off for the other.
JULIET EHUMIAN
CHIAZOR: Balancing.
OBY EZEKWESILI: Do you know why?
Because the capacity to express
all your realities already
in you.
So because they are
in you, what you
need is to be able
to say to yourself,
how do I keep expanding
and expanding?
And then there are days when
one particular reality is going
ahead of the other realities.
And you say to yourself,
I have observed
that this reality is suffering.
Let us recalibrate a bit.
So you're constantly
recalibrating,
but ensuring that no
reality gets forgotten.
Don't ever forget being a
wife, just because you want
to be the best radio owner.
Don't forget being
a great mother
just because you want to be TY
Bello, the global photographer.
Don't forget being
a daughter just
because you have
become a wonderful wife
enjoying your husband.
There has to be a way
that the Divine that's
given us all of
this, inside of us,
can help us to sort of
hold it all together.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Hold it all together.
TY BELLO: Together.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: I think
that's a very powerful note
on which to wrap up.
A big thank you
to Oby Ezekwesili.
OBY EZEKWESILI: Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Thank you.
You've committed this day to us.
You have been on this for--
I do, I am very grateful.
OBY EZEKWESILI: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
I owe you one.
OBY EZEKWESILI: Let
me reveal your secret.
I told her on [INAUDIBLE],
let me go back.
This flight, the amount
of delay that they
say they have is too much.
It's going to be so unproductive
for me to sit at the airport.
So let me go home.
And I was hoping that
she was going to say, oh
actually, that's not bad.
She said, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
Please don't go home.
I think you should just
wait at the airport.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: Are
you guys not glad I did?
TY BELLO: Yes.
OBY EZEKWESILI: Yes.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR: Aha!
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you very much.
And thank you, TY Bello.
TY BELLO: Thank you.
Want
JULIET EHUMIAN CHIAZOR:
You've also been with us
for quite a few hours now.
TY BELLO: Thank you.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Through both sessions.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you for your leadership,
for your inspiration.
TY BELLO: Thank you.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
And thank you
for spending this time with us.
OBY EZEKWESILI: Thank you.
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
And thank you
everyone that has
shared this day with us.
We look forward to
continuing the conversation
around women really stepping up
and standing out and breaking,
smashing the glass
ceiling, if there is one.
OBY EZEKWESILI: Yes.
You've got to kick it!
JULIET EHUMIAN-CHIAZOR:
Great, thank you very much.
OBY EZEKWESILI: Thank you.